in the last video we learned a little
bit about aldehydes about aldehydes and
we saw that they had the general
structure where you have a carbonyl
group bonded to some type of carbon
chain or I guess in the simplest form
this could just be a hydrogen over here
and then they definitely will have at
least one hydrogen bonded to the carbon
in the carbonyl group so this was an
aldehyde now very closely related to an
aldehyde is a type of molecule called a
ketone and let's draw a couple of
ketones just to make things clear and
then we'll think about what the
difference is between a ketone and an
aldehyde so this right here ch3 ch3
carbon right over here we this right
here is a ketone and you say hey Sal
that looks very similar to an aldehyde I
have a carbonyl group in both so this
right here is a carbonyl group this
right here is a carbonyl group let me
write this car carbon eel we have a
carbonyl group in both we have a carbon
chain over here this could be a general
carbon chain here we have a methyl group
so how is this different and I think
you'll see it's this part that I haven't
highlighted yet in an aldehyde there's
two ways to think about an aldehyde you
could either say that look the carbonyl
group is at the end of a carbon chain so
the next thing over is going to be a
hydrogen or you could say that in an
aldehyde you have at least a one
hydrogen bonded to the carbonyl carbon
and the way I remember that so you have
a hi you have a hydrogen there and in
the ketone you don't the carbonyl group
is embedded in a carbon chain it is
bonded to at least is bonded to a carbon
on either side so over here you have a
carbon and the way that I remember the
difference and this is really just a
little bit of a mnemonic just to
memorize it is aldehyde has an H in it
aldehyde has an H in it there's an H
right over there and an aldehyde has a
hydrogen bonded to this carbon so now
that we at least have a reasonable
understanding of what a ketone is let's
name a few just to familiarize ourselves
so this right here is the simplest
possible ketone and it's called acetone
that's its common name it is called
acetone and actually the word ketone
comes from the german word for acetone
which was i think instead of a c there
they had a k' so it's like a cotone and
they said oh this is a ketone so this is
a common name another kind of
traditional or common way of naming
acetone and we'll see or of naming a
ketone is to name each of these groups
and it's kind of it's similar to the way
that we named ethers but instead of
writing the word ether at the end we
write the word ketone so here we have a
methyl group and we have another methyl
group so this would be so we have two
methyl groups right over here so this
would be dye dye methyl dimethyl ketone
this right here is dye methyl ketone and
then if you wanted the systematic way of
naming it you just look at the longest
carbon chain which is one two three
carbons so it's probe propa and instead
of calling it propane we get rid of that
a over there and we'd call it propanone
we could call it propanone that tells us
that this right here is a ketone and you
have to know where this double bond and
actually four propanone you don't have
to specify it because if you know it's a
ketone you know that it has to have a
carbon on either side of the carbonyl
group so you actually don't even have to
specify where the carbonyl group is but
if you wanted to you could say okay
that's going to be on the two carbon no
matter what direction you start counting
from it's going to be on the two carbon
but the two is kind of optional for
propanone the two is optional for
propanol let's do a couple of other ones
so let's say we had let's say we had a
molecule that look like this let's say
we have a molecule that looks like this
so the traditional way of naming it
you'd say okay on this end of the ketone
i have one two three carbons so on that
end i have three carbons that is a
propyl group that is a propyl group and
on this other side of the ketone right
over here i have only one carbon that is
a methyl group that is a methyl group so
then you would just name them when you
name them in order of increasing chain
size or carbon just or
or Argus molecule site or group size so
this would you write methyl first methyl
because it's only one carbon so it's
this is methyl propyl methyl propyl
methyl propyl ketone methyl propyl
ketone this is kind of the traditional
or the common way so often kind of the
most used way of naming this molecule
but the systematic way of naming it you
look at the longest carbon chain and you
say okay I have one two three four five
carbons so it's going to be pent and
then you want to start numbering it so
that the ketone carbon or the carbonyl
carbon I should say has the lowest
possible number so you want to start
numbering on the right side 1 2 3 4 & 5
so this right here so we said the prefix
would be pent so it's pent tun and
instead of saying it's pentane you say
it's pentanone Penta Penta known and to
specify where the carbonyl group is you
say it's - this is - pentanone and you
might also see it written like this you
might also see it written as Penta
Penton Penton - 2 own either one of
these right here would be acceptable
let's do a slightly more complicated
example let's say we had something that
looked like this so we have something a
molecule that looked like this let me
stick some chlorines over here so what
would this be well our longest chain
once again is this cyclohexane 1 2 3 4 5
6 carbons I'll just name this
systematically right here and the more
complicated things get the more
systematic people will want to name it
so if we have six carbons right here and
they're in a chain so this is cyclo
cyclo hexane you would put the e there
if this was just and this was if this
carbonyl group wasn't there but since it
is we would call this cyclohexanone so
this right here tells us to name it
cyclo hexa known and then you know in a
ring like this this would implicitly be
the number 1
carbon so this is the number one carbon
and we're going to we're going to we
want to number in the direction so that
the next groups have the lowest possible
number so we want to make this the two
carbon so this is to to die chloro
cyclohexanone so this is to to die
chloro dichloro cyclohexanone now
there's two more and I'll just show
these to you because these are tend to
be referred to by their common names so
I just want to show them to you real
fast one is this molecule right here
where we have a methyl group on this
side ch3 and over here we have a benzene
ring we have a benzene ring over here
now that first super simple ketone that
we saw we call this acetone and so the
common name here is actually driven from
acetone instead of calling it acetone
because it doesn't have just a methyl
group here this is called this is called
acid acid tow and instead of acetone its
acetophenone because we have this phenyl
group that benzene ring right there
acetophenone which is a pretty common
molecule you'll see and you'll see it
referred to this way now the other the
other one that you might see every now
and then i just want to expose it to you
is a molecule that looks like this that
has two benzene rings on it so it has
two benzene rings on it
looks like that and this is benzophenone
benzo benzo vino
these last two I just really wanted to
expose you to their common names but in
general I think you have a decent idea
at this point of how to name at least
the simpler chains either with the
common names for example propyl or
methyl propyl ketone or two pentanone
and these are these are kind of the more
typical or maybe the easier naming
examples